olá eu sou é viu a carreira advogada por
razão educadora e professora por paixão
e palestrante por missão de vida que
tive o privilégio de desde muito muita
pouca idade descobrir o grande dom que é
a comunicação e desde os 9 anos
essa linda arte de se comunicar e a
pergunta que eu inicio a nossa conversa
é é educação fala eu acredito que a
associação deva ser sim é educação fala
porque pelo menos era isso que minha mãe
dizia é quando a gente entrar assim em
algum em algum lugar e dizer ver se fala
com as pessoas se bem gente que eu não
sofria muito esse problema na verdade
minha mãe dizer ver se não vai falar
pelos cotovelos então meu problema já
era outro e aí eu volto à pergunta que
motiva a nossa conversa educação fala e
eu não vou me alongar e da resposta é
educação sim ela fala por vezes ela
grita e quando ela se silencia ela fala
mais ainda
e qual então a minha proposta que hoje é
exatamente terceiro uma relação entre
educação e comunicação
na verdade a forma como nos comunicamos
é a forma como fomos educados a nos
comunicar a nossa comunicação ela está e
intimamente ligada
há os padrões comportamentais a que
fomos submetidos e aos valores que
carregamos aos valores que nos
fundamentam isso vale pra uma pessoa
guarnecido em sua individualidade
isso vale para uma família e isso vale
para uma empresa e isso vale para uma
nação para uma sociedade e para um país
e à comunicação ela está intimamente
relacionada com o outro ponto que é o
relacionamento
então é isso o tripé educação define o
nosso comportamento e a nossa
comunicação é reflexo disso tudo ea
forma como nos relacionamos ela define
muito de nós ea comunicação é um
elemento fundamental pra isso com o
melhor profissional aquele que adaptou
de um conhecimento máximo da sua área ou
aquele que se relaciona melhor com o seu
cliente com o seu paciente
qual é o professor melhor é aquele que
pauta sua aula numa vasta bibliografia
ou aquele que cria com os seus alunos
uma relação a ponto de criar um ambiente
favorável à a construção do conhecimento
qual é o pai ou a mãe melhor aquele que
fala e impõe a sua verdade ou aquele que
abre espaço para o diálogo e procura
compreender a necessidade de seus filhos
escutando os então está mais do que
claro que investir em comunicação é
investir em
ré relacionamento e é isso que nos
define então é muito importante saber
que todo comportamento é uma forma em si
de se comunicar
nós nos comunicamos o tempo inteiro
inclusive quando não falamos nada e olha
que interessante 93% na nossa
comunicação é definida pela forma como
nos comunicamos na linguagem corporal
pelo ritmo timbre de nossa voz e só 7%
estão nas palavras isso significa dizer
que não existe não comunicação
todos vocês estão se comunicando ainda
que estejam em silêncio e atentos e por
muitos anos e me dedicando a estudar
isso foram muitos livros tentando
decifrar a comunicação corporal a
comunicação corporal
foram muitos treinamentos muitos estudos
para saber o que é uma comunicação
estratégica aplicada processo de
negociação e de gestão de carreira
dediquei-me alguns anos a estudar a
oratória a arte de falar em público mas
foi recentemente que eu tive contato com
uma outra modalidade de comunicação que
simplesmente soou como música para os
meus amigos ouvidos comunicação não
violenta ou simplesmente sem ver a
comunicação não violenta nada mais é do
que um processo de comunicação que
inspira a empatia ea compaixão e cria
mecanismos práticos para ela foi
sistematizada
logo chamado marcham roseberg e a partir
do momento que eu comecei a estudar a
cnv eu vi que ela era aplicada há várias
coisas por exemplo as relações
familiares
assim revela é utilizada para apaziguar
conflitos entre pais e filhos entre
irmãos
a cmv ela é também utilizada nas escolas
para dirimir conflitos entre professores
e alunos professores e diretores
professores entre si alunos entre si
hoje a cnn vela é utilizada no poder
judiciário como com uma proposta de se
adotar métodos alternativos de solução
de conflitos em que se retira uma
justiça retributiva que paga o mal com o
mal ainda maior
dividindo a sociedade em vítimas e
algozes inocentes e culpados e coloca no
lugar uma justiça restaurativa capaz de
restaurar relacionamentos e vejo a cnv
sendo aplicada às empresas porque mais
do que nunca se constatou que os klein o
clima organizacional das empresas tem
sido impactado pela forma como os seus
líderes e liderados se comunicam e
marchou ele disse que nós fomos educados
adotar a a que há a comunicação não
violenta é pautada em dois princípios
básicos todo o ato violento é uma
expressão trágica de uma necessidade não
atendida e por trás de todo o
comportamento existe uma necessidade
então pra compreender o outro é
necessário criar espaço para que ele
revele a sua necessidade e aí então
macho diz
fomos educados a ter uma linguagem
chacal
o que é uma linguagem chacal é uma
linguagem que julga quem está certo e
quem está errado quem adota linguagem
chacal na verdade é aquela pessoa que
joga um jogo que todo mundo aqui joga o
jogo de quem está com a razão
é aquela famosa frase numa relação que
você diz assim eu te disse que isso ia
acontecer
eu falei eu aviso não precisa a pessoa
já está se sentindo mal com a situação
não precisa dizer isso mas a gente é
chacal e por isso fomos educados a seja
calma e aí então ele propõe uma outra
comunicação
a comunicação da girafa que a
comunicação do amor ea girafa é o
símbolo da cnv e porque quer gerar foi o
símbolo da cnv porque a girafa
dentre os mamíferos é a que tem o maior
coração então a linguagem gerar fé essa
linguagem que permite a empatia ea
compaixão que não procura culpados ou
inocentes e recentemente eu vive um
conflito em minha casa que colocava em
xeque uma das relações mais importantes
da minha vida eu tenho uma babá que
trabalha comigo há exatos seis anos que
é exatamente o tempo de vida do mesmo do
meu filho mais velho e tea se assim como
ela é chamada é uma pessoa extremamente
amável é uma parceira de todas as horas
caberia um ted só para falar das
peripécias minha detinha seio e aí a eu
fiz recentemente uma viagem aos estados
unidos estava palestrando para
empreendedores brasileiros e quando eu
retornei é eu entreguei a tia se um
presente quer exatamente o presente que
ela havia me pedido
advinha calcinhas era isso que ela havia
me pedido
eu entreguei para ela e aí a eu comecei
a mostrar para ela as outras coisas que
eu havia trazido para os nossos filhos e
por um determinado momento houve uma
frustração muito grande e assim porque a
sensação que ela me transmitiu é de que
ela esperava algo mais é de que é aquilo
ali não é não representava muita coisa
pra ela e então eis que o chacal tomou
conta de mim e eu pensava sobre eu sou
obrigada a aaa da presente a pessoa quer
dizer que a pessoa estava preocupado com
que a receber do que com o meu retorno
rocha tinha 70 mi soando uma tremenda
interesseira e eis que bloqueou em mim
qualquer possibilidade de desenvolver
empatia pela primeira vez em seis anos
eu fiquei sem falar direito com ti assim
e aquilo gerou um clima em nossa casa
tão terrível que estava fazendo mal para
todos inclusive para as crianças
e então veio em mim aquela inspiração
você está estudando tanto fazendo
treinamentos
lendo livros e artigos sobre comunicação
não violenta um conflito instaurado em
sua casa e você não tem a capacidade de
aplicar o seu conhecimento
nerd estudioso é essa que você agora no
coloca à prova
se você de fato está aprendendo sobre
essa que não comunicação sobre essa
comunicação não viola
e aí eu resolvi aplicar os quatro passos
da cnv fato sentimento nem fato
sentimento necessidade e pedido rompe o
silêncio de oito dias chamei tinha-se
pra conversar e narrei os fatos do
jeitinho que aconteceu
não procurei fazer julgamentos ou me
justificar narrei os fatos assim como
eles aconteceram
estávamos nós no quarto eu te entregar
um presente que mostrei os demais
você falou que esperava mais
e do jeito que as coisas aconteceram e
depois eu disse o meu sentimento
eu me sentia angustiada
eu me senti com raiva sim a gente deve
reconhecer nossos sentimentos
a gente tem que ter compaixão com nós
mesmos somos humanos
porém não é legal falar eu me sentir
frustrada porque a frustração você
atribui a outra responsabilidade porque
foi você que criou expectativa e ele que
te frustrou e aí então depois de ter
descrito e sentimentos eu falei tinha se
a minha necessidade era de compreensão
eu precisava ser relevado anmp o dia
fazer compras eu fui a trabalho e
faltando três dias para a minha viagem
eu fraturei o pé e fui de muleta
robofoot e cadeira de rodas nos estados
unidos palestra' então eu não tive tempo
de fazer o que normalmente as pessoas
fazem nos estados unidos
compras então aquilo significou muito
pra mim então eu te peço aí vem o pedido
desculpas porque na verdade tinha se eu
te julguei por um episódio
por sua trajetória de seis anos de
nossas vidas
eu estava prestes a perder uma das
pessoas mais importantes que divide
comigo a responsabilidade de cuidar de
meus filhos
juntamente com o meu amada esposa e de
repente eu vi como a cnv ela pode de
fato é resgatar relacionamentos que
sendo aplicada ela de fato constrói a
relação entre as pessoas e de repente
nós nos abraçamos e colocamos coração
com o coração
a empatia se fez presente à compaixão se
fez presente e eu percebi que nós sim
podemos educar a nossa comunicação
nós podemos educar a nossa comunicação
para não sermos abismo
para sermos pontes entre as pessoas
unindo coração com o coração muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]